well this is a small headline full but
it disguises a large rise in food
inflation which is causing pressure to
families up and down the country as they
see their cost of their weekly food shop
go up
and it shows that there is no such thing
as an automatic fall in the headline
rate of inflation that's why we have a
plan and if we're going to reduce that
pressure on families it's absolutely
essential that we stick to that plan and
we see it through so that we halve
inflation this year as the Prime
Minister has promised core inflation
looks stubborn the UK has the highest
inflation rate of the G7 Nations why is
that and do you worry that inflation is
becoming embedded in the economy we have
to watch that carefully but it's
important to say Although our core
inflation is marginally higher than
other countries Germany for example has
higher food price inflation than we have
so this is a common problem that we're
all facing and when I talk to my
colleagues at the international monetary
fund everyone is very clear that the UK
is on the right track to focus on
bringing down inflation and if we do
that we can get through this very
difficult period and make sure that
we're not having the same discussion
this time next year and that we can get
back to growth which is what we want to
see